I made a video about a gigantic circuit
with light second long wires that
connect up to a light bulb which is just
one meter away from the battery and
switch and I asked you after I close the
switch how long will it take for us to
get light from that light bulb and my
answer was one over C seconds and his
answer is wrong we would be able to
communicate faster than the speed of
light that violates causality and Common
Sense this is actually a bit misleading
misleading misleading in a way extremely
unconvinced naughty Mr veritasium has
stood on a right Hornet's Nest clearly I
did not do a good job of explaining what
was really going on in the last video so
I want to clear up any confusion that I
created so behind me we have a scaled
down model of this circuit it is only 10
meters in length on either side
obviously that's a lot shorter than one
light second but for the first 30
nanoseconds this model should be
identical to the big circuit and Caltech
has very fast Scopes so we'll be able to
see what's going on in this time I got a
ton of help on this from Richard Abbott
who works on ligo the gravitational wave
detector over here we are going to put a
little resistor which is going to be the
stand-in for our light bulb and we're
going to measure it with a scope
and see essentially what is the time
delay between applying a pulse on the
other side basically flicking the switch
for us to get a voltage across our
resistor and the magnitude of that
voltage is really important a lot of
people thought it would be negligible
the amount of energy supplied by this is
so minuscule a tiny tiny effect right
the amount of power you're getting to
the lamp over here it's naffle immense
the light turns on at any current level
immediately that is not what I meant
well actually with that assumption
Derek's answer is wrong the light never
turns off no matter the state of the
switch some electrons will jump the Gap
and result in an extremely small
continuous leakage current let me be
clear about what I am claiming okay it
is my claim that we will see voltage and
current through the load that is many
orders of magnitude greater than leakage
current an amount of power that would
actually produce visible light if you
put it through an appropriate nice and
we will see that power there in roughly
the time it takes light to cross the one
meter Gap but to understand why this
happens we first have to clear up some
misconceptions that I saw in responses
misconception number one is thinking
that electrons carry the energy from the
battery to the bulb
let's say we have a simple circuit with
a battery and a bulb operating at steady
state if you zoom in on the light bulb
filament you'd see a lattice of
positively charged cores of atoms the
nucleus and lowest shells of electrons
surrounded by a sea of negative
electrons which are free to move around
the lattice the actual speed of these
electrons is very fast around a million
meters per second but all in random
directions the average drift velocity of
an electron is less than 0.1 millimeters
per second
now frequently an electron will bump
into a metal ion and transfer some or
all of its kinetic energy to the lattice
the electron slows down and the metal
lattice starts wiggling more it heats up
and ultimately this is what causes the
filament to glow and emit light so a lot
of people will look at this and conclude
the electron carried the energy from the
battery to the bulb where it dissipated
its kinetic energy as heat
but consider where did the electron get
its kinetic energy from before the
Collision it didn't carry that energy
from the battery in fact if the circuit
has only been on for a short time that
electron hasn't been anywhere near the
battery so how is it accelerated before
the Collision the answer is it was
accelerated by an electric field in The
Wire the electron repeatedly collides
with the lattice and loses energy and
after each Collision it is again
accelerated by the electric field so
although it is the electron that
transfers energy to the lattice the
energy came from the electric field
so where does that electric field come
from well a lot of animations make it
look like the electrons push each other
through the circuit via their Mutual
repulsion so you might think the
electric field comes from the electron
behind it there is the analogy of water
flowing through a hose or marbles in a
tube this is misconception too thinking
that mobile electrons push each other
through the circuit that is not how
electrons flow in circuits the truth is
if you average over a few atoms you find
the charge density everywhere inside a
conductor is zero the negative charge of
electrons and the positive cores of
atoms perfectly cancel out so for each
repulsive force between electrons there
is an equal and opposite force from the
positive ion next to it these forces
cancel out so mobile electrons cannot
push each other through the wire so
where does the electric field come from
misconception number three is that it
comes entirely from the battery this
makes intuitive sense since the battery
is the active element in the circuit it
has a positive side and a negative side
so it has an electric field but this is
not the electric field that all the
electrons within the wire experience
consider that the electric field of the
battery is much larger close to the
battery so if its field were really
what's pushing the electrons around then
if you brought the light bulb close to
the battery then the bulb would glow
much brighter and it doesn't the truth
is that the electric field in the wire
comes both from the battery and from
charges on the surface of the wires of
the circuit
as you go along the wire from the
negative end of the battery to the
positive end there is a gradient of
charge built up on its surface starting
with an excess of electrons through to
roughly no charge in the middle as we'll
see the steepest charge gradient is
actually across the load to a deficiency
of electrons the exposed positive cores
of atoms on the surface of the positive
end of The Wire
all these charges and the charges on the
battery create the electric field
everywhere inside the wires they also
create an electric field in the space
around the wires
these surface charges were set up almost
instantaneously when the battery was
inserted into the circuit you might
think you'd have to move electrons a
significant distance to create this
charge distribution but that is not the
case even a slight expansion or
contraction of the electron C with
electrons moving on average the radius
of a proton can establish the surface
charges you see
so the time for the charges to move is
completely negligible and the speed of
the setup process is limited only by the
speed of light
once that surface charge distribution
has been established the battery does
continuous work to maintain it by moving
electrons through the battery against
the coulomb force
in the load the electric field created
by all the surface charges accelerates
electrons which dissipate their energy
in collisions with the lattice so the
battery is putting energy into the field
which electrons take out and transfer to
the load
an electrical engineer who made a
response video Ben Watson came up with a
good analogy the battery is Like a
Shepherd the surface charges are the
sheep dogs responding to his orders and
the mobile electrons are the Sheep
Guided by those barking dogs
the surface charge description of
electric circuits is omitted from most
textbooks but there is a great treatment
of it in matter and interactions by
shabai and Sherwood
they also have a v python simulation
where you can see the positive surface
charge in red and negative surface
charge in blue you can see how this
entire charge distribution creates a net
electric field shown by the orange arrow
everywhere in and around the circuit
everywhere inside the wire the electric
field has the same magnitude and its
direction is along the wire this is
really showing you the electric field in
the center of the wire but it's depicted
on the surface so you can see it
in this circuit all the conductors are
made of the same material but the
segment at the bottom has a much
narrower cross section so it represents
a resistor since the cross-sectional
area is smaller the electron drift
velocity through the resistor has to be
higher so that it can carry the same
current as everywhere else in the
circuit now drift velocity is directly
proportional to electric field so the
electric field must be largest inside
the resistor and this is achieved by
having the steepest gradient of surface
charges here
you can also see the contribution to the
net electric field from the battery in
magenta and the contribution from
surface charges in green
far from the battery most of the
electric field is due to surface charges
whereas close to the battery it has a
greater contribution and the field due
to surface charges is actually in the
opposite direction to the field from the
battery
so to sum up electrons don't carry the
energy from Battery to bulb nor do they
push each other through the wire they
are pushed Along by an electric field
which is created by charges on the
battery and charges on the surface of
the wires with this view of circuits
things that might have previously seemed
mysterious make a lot more sense like if
electrons leave a battery at the same
rate and with the same drift velocity as
they return how do they carry energy
from the battery
the answer is they don't they are
accelerated by the electric field before
each collision with the lattice
at a junction how do the correct number
of electrons go down each path well they
are Guided by the electric field which
extends everywhere throughout the
circuit the fields are the main actors
extending everywhere throughout the
circuit and the electrons are just their
Pawns
so how does this apply to the big
circuit when the battery is connected
into the circuit even with the switch
open charges rearrange themselves on the
negative side of the battery there is an
excess of electrons on the surface of
the wires and the switch on the positive
side there is a deficiency of electrons
so positive charge is built up on the
surface of the wires the charges
rearrange themselves until the electric
field is zero everywhere inside the
conductor
this electric field is due to all the
surface charges and the charges on the
battery
there is an electric field outside the
wires due to these charges but it's zero
inside the wires we now have the full
potential difference of the battery
across the switch and no current is
Flowing except for leakage current which
I'll assume is negligible
when we close the switch the surface
charges on both sides of the switch
neutralize each other on contact and at
that instant the electric field inside
the conductor is no longer zero and
current starts flowing through the
switch
simultaneously the new electric field
from the modified surface charges
radiates outwards at essentially the
speed of light and when it reaches the
bulb the electric field inside it is no
longer zero so current starts to flow
here too this is why I said the bulb
lights up in one over C seconds because
the bulb was one meter from the switch
and the change in the electric field
travels out at the speed of light
as some of you pointed out the answer
should have been one meter divided by C
and I apologize for the Casual use of
units if you were to move the switch
then the bulb would take a different
amount of time to emit light which just
depends on the distance between the
switch and the bulb
in response to my original video Ben
Watson simulated a model of the circuit
using software from ansys called hfss it
provides a complete solution to
Maxwell's equations in three dimensions
now I have worked with Ben and ansys to
make these simulations when the switch
is closed you can see the electric field
radiate out and as it hits the far wire
it generates current the electric field
is to the right so the electrons flow to
the left
this simulation shows the magnitude of
the magnetic field which falls off
pretty rapidly as it crosses the Gap but
then a magnetic field appears around the
far wire and this magnetic field is
created by the current in that wire
to me this suggests that it really is
the electric field and not the changing
magnetic field that creates the current
through the load
some commenters on the original video
claimed my answer of three or four
nanoseconds violates causality I guess
they were thinking that the bulb would
only go on if the circuit were complete
and it wouldn't if the circuit were
broken somewhere which could be up to
half a light second away so it seemed
like I was saying we could get
information about the status of the
whole circuit even half a light second
away in just nanoseconds but that is not
what I was saying what I should have
stated explicitly is that the bulb goes
on regardless of whether the circuit is
complete or not the current flows
through the load due to the electric
field it experiences
to illustrate this Ben added a wire
below the circuit that is completely
disconnected from it and what you can
see is that its response to the changing
electric field is virtually identical to
that of the top wire at least up until
the signal reaches the far end and
reflects back
this is why my answer doesn't break
causality at least initially connected
and disconnected wires behave exactly
the same
using this software you can also
simulate the pointing Vector that is the
cross product of electric and magnetic
fields in the last video I showed how
the pointing Vector indicates the
direction of energy flow and after the
switch is closed the pointing Vector
points out of the battery across the Gap
to the other wire whether connected or
not because energy is carried by fields
and not electrons it can go straight
across the gap
so you might ask why do we need wires at
all well we don't I mean phones and
toothbrushes charge without wires
connecting them to a stream of electrons
and researchers have demonstrated remote
charging using the energy from Wi-Fi
signals wires are more efficient because
they channel the fields and hence the
energy from source to load here's
another angle on the pointing Vector you
can see once there is current in the top
wire the fields around it carry energy
in both directions now of course the
pointing Vector also points parallel to
the first wire carrying the energy
around the circuit as most people would
expect but again note how the energy is
carried outside the wires not in the
wires
now admittedly thinking about circuits
this way is complicated and since nobody
wants to solve Maxwell's equations in
three dimensions just to analyze a basic
circuit scientists and Engineers have
worked out shortcuts for example Ohm's
law voltage equals current times
resistance is just the macroscopic
result of all the surface charges their
electric fields and zillions of
electrons bumping into zillions of metal
ions you can simplify all that physics
into a single circuit element a resistor
and the basic quantities of current and
voltage this is called the lumped
element model lump all the spread out
multi-particle and field interactions
into a few discrete circuit elements and
we use this technique every time we draw
a circuit diagram
so our original diagram of the big
circuit is flawed because Fields between
the wires are important to the problem
but there are no circuit elements to
indicate these interactions to fix it we
need to add capacitors all down the
wires these capture the effect charges
on one wire have on the other if there
are negative charges on the surface of
the bottom wire for example they'll
induce positive charges on the surface
of the top wire
also since these wires are long they're
going to create significant magnetic
fields around them which resist changes
in current so we model this with
inductors all the way down the wires we
could also add resistors making what
electrical engineers would recognize as
the distributed element model for a
transmission line but we're assuming
that these wires are super conducting so
this is how we could Model A
superconducting transmission line
this diagram offers another way of
understanding why current flows through
the load almost immediately when you
first apply a voltage across a capacitor
current flows as opposite charge builds
up on the two plates in the short time
limit a capacitor is a short circuit it
acts just like an ordinary wire once
it's charged up no more current flows
but by this point the next capacitor is
charging up and then the next one and
then the next one and so we have a loop
of current that is expanding out at
roughly the speed of light this is of
course just another way of talking about
the effect the electric field from the
bottom wire has on the top wire one
reason it's useful to look at the
circuit this way is because you can use
the values of inductance and capacitance
to calculate the characteristic
impedance of the transmission lines you
can think of this as the resistance to
alternating current that a source would
see when sending a signal down the wires
the characteristic impedance is equal to
the square root of of inductance divided
by capacitance and for our circuit I
measured the capacitance and the
inductance of the lines 11.85 call it
micro Henry's so we got a characteristic
impedance of about 550 ohms
to maximize the power delivered to our
load we want its resistance to equal the
sum of the other impedances in the
circuit so that's why we picked a 1.1
kilo Ohm resistor now I hope you're
convinced that current will flow as soon
as the electric field reaches the far
wire the question is how much are we
going to see an appreciable voltage even
with these lines a meter apart that's
what it seemed like a lot of people were
doubting in the last video so that's
really what we want to find out here
foreign
looking Derek
so what do we got that yellow one is our
got a fraction of the applied voltage
overshoot and then so it looks to me
like the initial voltage that we're
getting is about five volts per division
so it looks like about five volts
roughly four or five volts the green
curve rising up to around 18 volts is
the source voltage and the yellow line
is the voltage across the resistor so
after just a few nanoseconds this
voltage Rises to around 4 volts since
the resistor was a kilo ohm that means
four milliamps of current are flowing in
the resistor before the signal goes all
the way around the circuit so we were
transferring about 14 milliwatts of
power this is what 14 milliwatts of
light actually looks like so yeah it's
not a fully on bulb but it is visible
light and way more than you would get
from just leakage current now some of
you may argue it's unfair to use a
little LED when I showed a bulb and car
battery in the original video but those
items were for illustrative purposes
only the clue that this is actually a
thought experiment is the two light
seconds of superconducting wire that
stretch out into space this is not an
engineering question about how best to
wire fire up a light bulb in your
bedroom
the question was intentionally vague and
if you want to choose circuit components
such that the bulb never goes on you are
welcome to do that and I support your
conclusion just to me the most
interesting way to approach this problem
is to ask how could you make the light
go on fastest I was worried that those
long wires would pick up all the radio
waves passing through and we wouldn't
even be able to see the signal for that
noise but you can see clearly on the
graph that the signal is way above the
noise level Alpha Phoenix set up a
kilometer of wire and got a very similar
result so the light bulb turns on a
little bit and then after one light
speed delay the light bulb turns on the
rest of the way
YouTuber zy simulated the transmission
line circuit and found that even with
realistic assumptions he transferred 12
milliwatts to the load straight away
Derek is actually more correct than we
give him credit for so I believe that
he's correct on all counts and the
question is neither deceptive or
requires like technicalities
so everyone agrees that a steady small
but way bigger than leakage current
signal flows through the load in the
first second after the switch is closed
is it enough to emit light
yes if you use an LED
but the point of the thought experiment
was to reveal something that's normally
hidden by the way that we think about
and teach electric circuits you know we
use voltage and current and lumped
elements because they're more convenient
than working with Maxwell's equations
but we shouldn't forget that the main
actors are actually the fields they are
what carry the energy
and you don't have to take my word for
it this is Rick Hartley a veteran
printed circuit board designer I used to
think in terms of old age and current
and I used to think that the energy in a
circuit was in the voltage and current
but it's not the energy in a circuit is
in the fields the most important thing
you need to know is that when you route
a trace you better Define the other side
of that transmission line because if you
don't that's those fields are going to
spread and they're going to leave you an
unhappy individual I think one of the
things that I'm most excited about the
circuits video was the response videos I
saw by so many people especially people
with far better credentials in
electrical engineering than me I really
enjoyed watching those videos so I feel
like my circuits video was kind of like
a mistake on my part in certain ways
that I didn't delve deep enough into
this part of the problem I honestly
didn't think that this was the focus of
the video but clear clearly everyone who
watched it did so that's on me but by
making that mistake and by not going
deep into my explanation I invited
seemingly a whole bunch of other people
to make explanations which I thought
were great and some people like Alpha
Phoenix even took up the challenge and
set up his own version of the experiment
so uh frankly I'm just really excited at
what came about even though I do
acknowledge that this was my fault in
the first place like I should have done
a better explanation
but by not doing so you know there are a
lot of great explanations out there and
and uh and that's what I love so I'm
going to recommend a whole bunch of
electrical engineering YouTubers to you
in case you want to go check those out
because there are a lot of great
channels and you should really see how
they think about electronics and how
they explain the circuit
this video is entered by brilliant the
website an app that gets you thinking
deeply about Concepts in math science
and computer science brilliant is
sponsoring a lot of our videos this year
because they know someone who makes it
to the end of a veritasium video is
exactly the sort of person who would
love to learn with brilliant and they
have a great course on electricity and
magnetism which methodically steps you
through an introduction to e m with
questions simulations videos and
experiments I really think this is the
best way to learn because the sequence
of steps is so well thought out the
difficulty builds gradually and by
asking you questions you are forced to
check your understanding at each step if
you need help there's always a useful
hint or explanation you know what sets
brilliant apart is their interactivity
you can learn calculus or machine
learning or computer science
fundamentals all in this very active way
so I encourage you to go over to
brilliant.org veritasium and just take a
look at their courses I will put that
link down in the description and if you
click through right now brilliant are
offering 20 off an annual premium
subscription to the first 200 people to
sign up so I want to thank brilliant for
supporting veritasium and I want to
thank you for watching